neben der außenpolitik für sie
entscheidend als kanzlerkandidatin
natürlich die innenpolitik oder sind
zwei themen die unsere lisa vor allem
beschäftigt haben das ist einmal das
autofahren deswegen habe ich hier ein
modell mitgebracht das ist ein suv viel
diskutiert und ebenfalls mitgebracht
eingriff steak was theoretisch direkt
auf den grill könnte die zwei themen
haben unsere leser tatsächlich am
meisten beschäftigt und deswegen fragt
alexander manske aus dresden wie ihre
partei zum grillen steht ob das erlaubt
bleibt und bei welchem preis fürs tanken
die grünen in den nächsten vier jahren
die obergrenze erreichen oder was die
obergrenze ist vor der burg fangen wir
mit dem auto fahren an sind sie schon
mal mit dem hunger dann fangen wir nicht
dann kann das ist das ist ein schönes
steak das stimmt würden würde ihn das
schmecken grillen sie ab und zu zu hause
ja ich hab jetzt dieses frühe ehrlich
gesagt die mannschaft nachdenken ich
glaube noch gar nicht gegrillt aber
eigentlich gerade ich sehr gerne was
kommt bei ihnen normalerweise offen
grill gemischt
ich weiß gar nicht ob unser gerät groß
genug ist für dieses stück fleisch aber
da kommen auch würstchen drauf der
kleine würstchen für die kleinen am
tisch gerne auch gefüllte pilze und
auberginen aber auch mein gutes stück
fleisch und wie grillen sie holzkohle
oder gas was ist da ihre präferenz kohle
die zertifiziert ist kohle die
zertifiziert ist und wenn viele menschen
jetzt angst haben nehmen wir an sie
werden kanzler und dieses stück fleisch
gebe es dann zu kaufen wird das dann
viel viel teurer werden oder wird das
den ähnlichen preis haben ich weiß nicht
was sie zu sein deutsch ist ein
regionales ich hoffe aus brandenburg ja
ist es ein steak aus brandenburg weil er
regionale lebensmittel ist dass ich
glaube was die allermeisten menschen
auch am liebsten essen wenn sie wissen
der apfel ist doch vom bauern direkt um
die ecke oder das fleisch kommt aus dem
schönen brandenburg oder überall auch
deutsch anderswo in deutschland
her deswegen finde ich extrem es wichtig
dass man kennzeichnet wo kommt das
fleisch her
wie wurde das tier gehalten wir haben
das zum beispiel bei den eiern gesehen
da hat renate künast lange zeit ist er
als damalige grüne umweltministerin
eingeführt dass bei den eiern
gekennzeichnet wird ist das jetzt aus
massentierhaltung ist das von
freilaufenden hühnern oder von bio
hühnern und siehe da die meisten
menschen wollten am liebsten eier von
glücklichen hühnern kaufen
und deswegen ist zum beispiel die die
käfighaltung von hühnern mit blick auf
die eier dramatisch zurückgegangen
sondern so stelle ich mir das auch beim
fleisch sollten die deutschen weniger
fleisch essen
jeder kann essen was er will in diesem
land aber ich möchte dass das fleisch
was auf den tisch kommt dass das gesund
ist und eltern mütter wissen dass da zum
beispiel keine antibiotika rückstände
drin sind weil es vorher in der
massentierhaltung anlage war aber im
wahlprogramm steht was anderes da sitzt
nach gesundes essen er hat oberste
priorität aber gesundes essen ist zwar
kein fleisch auch bank gleich okay dann
haben wir das fleisch abgang von berber
und kommen hier zum seo wie fahren das
ist das modell was wir hier mitgebracht
haben
wie wissen sie gehören ja auch den sound
vision es sich anhört war saßen sie da
schon mal drin insoweit da saß ich auch
schon mal drin ich glaube auch weil sie
den helm vorhin hatten als sich im irak
unterwegs war da war das fahrzeug aber
vor allem gepanzert können sie sich
vorstellen so etwas selbst zu fahren
oder wäre das für sie nichts ich bin
schon bei uns so gegen den garten tor
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich mit dem um die
ecke kommen würde
also da müssen schon ordentlich zwei
kindern sollte wobei der presse auch
zwei kinder so zu sein
wissen sie was ein liter super momentan
so kostet in brandenburg in brandenburg
159 so rund um die ecke keine ahnung wo
noch heute wahrlich schöne tankstellen
einzelnen 15 166 wird das teurer werden
robert habeck hat von 16 cent pro liter
mehr gesprochen und was ist dann mit den
berufspendlern zum beispiel sechs cent
erhöhung gab
jetzt zum jahresbeginn das ist natürlich
beim benzinpreis immer so da gibt es ja
ohnehin schwankungen wenn man sich
zurückerinnert früher als noch alle in
urlaub fahren konnten war das meistens
zu den ferien so oder ist der
benzinpreis erst mal hoch gegangen
ganz unabhängig von irgendwelchen
klimaschutzgründen zum anfang des jahres
hat es jetzt sechs cent erhöhung gegeben
weil erstmalig ein co2 preis auch auf
benzin jetzt neu mit eingeführte worden
ist und ja wir sagen dass sukzessive
also schrittweise das weiter angehoben
werden muss auf die 16 cent die robert
habeck erwähnt hat was mit dem fliegen
ein flug nach mallorca wie teuer wird
der werden wenn sie kanzlerin sind das
weiß ich nicht weil die flugpreise die
fluggesellschaften bestimmen und auch da
ist es leider so meistens zu
ferienzeiten wenn man dann mit den
kindern unterwegs ist dagegen die preise
richtig hoch und wenn dann keiner
fliegen will und meistens nur business
flüge sind dann gehen die preise richtig
runter und das halte ich für ziemlich
ungerecht und deswegen habe ich sehr
deutlich gemacht gerade für diese
strecken wo eigentlich nur unternehmen
oder diejenigen profitieren die einfach
mal kurze ums eck fliegen wollen dass
der preis da so sein muss dass er auch
die wahren kosten widerspiegelt was ist
mit dem tempo 130 wann wird das kommen
also wann kann man denen nicht mehr so
schnell fahren wie man möchte ja
meistens stehen diese autos in der stadt
ja eben stau und einer stadt fährt
hoffentlich niemand 130 wir sagen das
geradezu mit blick auf die
verkehrssicherheit da gibt es ja auch
viele studien zu mit blick auf tempo
lieme dass es sehr viel sicherer wäre
aber wenn es ein tempolimit gebe wir
würden das gerne in der nächsten
bundesregierung also wenn wir sehr stark
werden dann ist das einer der punkte den
wir in einem koalitionsvertrag mit
verhandeln das heißt dann wenn sie
kanzlerin würden sofort also wenn wir 50
prozent bei der nächsten bundestagswahl
bekämen dann könnten wir all unsere
punkte relativ schnell im bundestag
umsetzen da ich jetzt mal nicht davon
ausgehe dass es 50 prozent werden wird
dann entscheiden was es für eine
koalition gibt und welche gesetze der
bundestag verabschiedet aber ja das ist
ein punkt aus unserem wahlprogramm
coburg ein thema was
viele menschen bewegt ist das thema
gender und die frage was das aus unserem
land machen könnte ob das richtig ob das
falsch ich möchte einmal zeigen was die
wie die zdf journalistin nicole diekmann
bei maischberger geändert hat einerseits
natürlich unternehmer/innen
wissenschaftler/innen politiker innen
intensivmediziner innen beziehungsweise
mediziner in den forscherinnen die insel
bewohner innen sie die vielen pendler
innen wenn sie das so sehen wird dass
die zukunft sollen ja ich hoffe man
macht auch in zukunft subjekt prädikat
objekt und macht setzte wo man sagt die
insel bewohnerinnen freut sich sehr dass
es auf ihrer insel gute luft gibt dann
hat man nur einmal geändert
warum sagt man dich insel bewohnerinnen
und inselbewohner oder lehrerinnen und
lehrer das hört sich doch irgendwie
selbst sammeln oder ich sage das auch
meistens also ich sage meistens der
lehrerinnen und lehrer journalistinnen
und journalisten
das kann ja jeder entscheiden wie er ist
selber meint für richtig zu halten immer
mehr unis bestrafen wird studentinnen
und studenten die nicht richtig denn
dann finden sie das gut
was heißt bestrafen naja punkteabzüge
zum beispiel eine uni ist ja die frage
was vorher vereinbart wurde wie man
gemeinsam schreibt aber ich habe vorhin
mal so aus spaßeshalber weil ich ja
wusste dass diese frage zum ländern
kommen bei ihnen auf der website
geschaut beziehungsweise bei ihrem
verlag axel springer darauf geschaut und
da steht dann als empfehlung an alle
künftigen journalistinnen und
journalisten des axel springer verlages
dass man die unterschiedlichen formen
durch ausnutzen sollte weil sonst weiß
der leser oder die leserin gar nicht
wenn man vom arzt schreibt ob es jetzt
eine ärztin oder ein arzt worden ich
fand es eigentlich ganz klugen hinweis
dazu eine frage von unserem leser
christian grams
der stellt sich nämlich die frage wenn
ich die schlagzeilen und texte auf
bild.de leser habe ich den eindruck dass
bild.de eine politische agenda gegen die
grünen hat sehen sie das auch so frau
berger das ist nett das
ihre leserinnen und leser dass sich so
genauer anschauen ich war wie gesagt
über den untertitel hier gerade etwas
verwundert dass die bild schon wusste
was war ein kitsch pur sagt vitali
klitschko sagt was er da gar nicht
gesagt hat aber die headline schon
fertig produziert war
mal gucken was morgen in der zeitung
steht für die sagen zum abschluss frau
wirkt ein paar schnelle fragen mit ja
oder nein
gerne beantworten damit wir schnell
durch kommen sollten die schulen und
kindergärten sofort für alle geöffnet
werden ohne wechsel unterricht das kann
man nicht mit ja oder nein beantworten
weil es mit den instanzen zu tun hat die
meisten kindergärten sind schon wieder
offen die grundschulen kommen jetzt auch
und das halte ich für richtig überall wo
es möglich ist sofort die kinder wieder
hin zu schicken weil die haben heftig
gelitten im letzten jahr würden sie ihr
kind impfen lassen falls es zwölf werden
das hängt davon ab ob der impfstoff dann
offiziell zugelassen ist wenn er da ist
wenn er da ist wenn er zugelassen ist
wenn das empfohlen wird dann ja waren
sie schon einmal im kanzleramt zu
welcher gelegenheit zu besuch bei der
kanzlerin
vorher war ich ein bisschen zu jung wo
sie mal zurückrechnen wie alt ich
eigentlich war die kannst du dir viel
glück gewünscht von wolke ich war zu
einer anderen zeit da aber finden sie
das gebäude schön ja haben sie die möbel
fürs kanzleramt schon ausgesucht
warum sollte ich von ralph brinkhaus
davon gesprochen hat dass mehrere cdu
abgeordnete oder grünen abgeordnete
davon sprechen dass sie die möbel schon
ausgesucht hätten ich wundere mich sehr
dass ich die cdu solche gedanken bei uns
macht über unser wahlprogramm und jetzt
auch schon welche möbel wir in
irgendwelche häuser stellen wenn sie als
kanzlerin ein anruf ihrer kinder
bekommen und sie sind gerade in der
verhandlung gehen sie dran
das hängt davon ab wo von mit wem ich
gerade spreche auch dass der notruf call
meiner kinder ist oder das reguläre
telefon als die vorsitzender grün wurden
haben sie gesagt es gibt tage die
gehören den kindern komme was wolle
würde das auch für eine kanzlerin
berbalk es wird situationen einer
kanzlerschaft geben wo das
allerwichtigste dass kanzlerinnen amt
ist aber das weiß man vorher meistens
nicht das immer schwieriger
ich wurde außenpolitik halten sie es für
sinnvoll dass menschen in einem flugzeug
oder einem fußballstadion masten tagen
müssen obwohl alle geimpft chinesen oder
negativ getestet sind
auch das hängt davon ab wer gehen davon
aus dass die kinder nicht alle geimpft
werden sein
und die gehen hoffentlich auch in
zukunft weiterhin stadion und auch in
ein flugzeug während sie dafür dass der
dfb größter sportverband der welt
erstmals eine präsidentin bekommt das
wird der dfb für sich entscheiden
potenzielle gute frauen aber das weiß
glaube ich der deutsche fußball-bund
besser als ich waren sie verärgert dass
robert habe den eindruck erweckt habe
ich das hacken sie seien vor allem
deshalb kandidatin geworden weil sie
eine pause
das hat er nicht gesagt aber den
eindruck erweckt mein eindruck war ein
anderer
robert habe ich halt auch einmal gesagt
er weint manchmal wenn der filme schaut
weil sie auch manchmal bei film ja ich
wusste noch nicht dass wir das beide tun
da sollten wir mal zusammen könig der
löwen gucken sie sagen dass sie in der
kirche sind obwohl sie nicht an glaubt
gott glauben weil sie gemeinschaft
schätzen zum christsein gehört auch das
verzeihen können können sie boris palmer
wegen seines eintrags verzeihen
ich kann einen menschen fährt sein
herzlichen dank frau burke für ihn
besucht heute abend bei bild vielen dank
für die offene diskussion
vielen dank